welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host stephen grant and this video
we're breaking down moonlight episode 5.
cheers for that stevie g hope nothing
happens to you as that would weigh on my
heart quite a lot but i'm not a rapper
the episode has just dropped and there's
a ton of easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed in it that we're going
to be breaking down in this spoiler
filled recap it's somewhat of a trip
down memory lane that fills in some of
the blanks about the character and
hopefully with us talking about what
happens in the comics you should start
to get more of an appreciation for
what's going on in the show we're almost
at the end so we'd massively appreciate
the thumbs up and also don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss all our
prediction videos and breakdown of the
final episode without the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
moonlight episode 5. okay so last week
saw more coming too in a psychiatric
hospital that was filled with things
from throughout the season after coming
across stephen and the sarcophagus we
got a hint that there was a jake lockley
lock lead up in one and we met the
goddess tarouite i love the subtle
little details as they scream because
steven seemed terrified but if you look
at his hand he's actually trying to wave
back now her appearance was first hinted
at all the way back in episode 1 when
donna brought her up to stephen
bring those hippos up here will you yeah
sure
power wet it
the hippo goddess tower with it anyway
the episode is titled asylum and this of
course has many meanings not only does
it typically pertain to a hospital like
the one we get in this episode but it's
also a word used to describe when
someone is put under protection this of
course ties in with stephen who's even
referred to as a stress ball throughout
the episode now we begin with a
flashback to mark screaming and also his
mother saying that it's all his fault
there's a slight waterfall effect of
this which could be linking back to the
hr desk from episode 2. this is lately
revealed to be the apparent death of
mark's brother but we'll talk later on
about how the character could return
from here we seemingly pick up where we
left off but harrow pulls mark back into
the room by saying that it's all a
fantasy and that he has difficulty
grasping what's happening with reality
this is such a mind
and i love the way that the show
constantly keeps tricking us as to
what's going on we learn this is all
located in putnam which also pulls
directly from the comics now harrow of
course denies shooting mark and it is
possible that the reason he shot him two
times was to kill both mark and steven
he says that he refuses to look within
which this episode is very much about
now the ending of four in this opening
have slight nods to movies like shutter
island and 12 monkeys the latter
featured bruce willis as a time traveler
who went back to the 90s to stop a
killer virus from being released that
meant everyone would have to sit in the
house all day watching tiger king yay
however he went back too far and after
arriving in the early part of the decade
he was arrested and put into an insane
asylum it was difficult to tell for
about the first star of the film whether
he was really a time traveler or just
imagining the whole thing which i think
this episode could definitely also be
doing now earlier in the week i made a
video discussing about how there were
several clues in the season that showed
he'd been in the asylum the entire time
this seemingly gets debunked in this
entry and we learned that last week as
many suspected it was just his mind
trying to piece things together and
there are mentions of this being carried
out when people are trying to organize
their thoughts and thus they create a
fake reality for the entire thing harrow
wants mark to break down the walls
between him and stephen and he very much
acts as a psychiatrist actually trying
to help him i love the way it kind of
leaves things up in the air a bit and
you could genuinely look at things like
they're all in his mind now upon being
injected he returns back to the corridor
with stephen and tarauet which is pretty
damning i love it when he showed us
something like this and just in the same
way that we can see this all really
playing out you could argue it's just a
fantasy that mark is using to deal with
his psychosis now throughout the season
itself harrow has acted as somewhat of a
psychiatrist and not only mark but also
layla huge shout out to david lee who
pointed out how when stephen met harrow
that it was basically what happens when
a patient is introduced to a new care
facility he was handcuffed by the
orderlies taken in and then let go when
he met the doctor who then slowly walked
him through the compound appearing as a
friend there were people sat on
meditation pillows several watching
calming nature videos and harrow also
took steven to get some food from the
same line that everyone else was eating
from this is done in hospitals to show
that the food is safe to eat and when
layla arrived things got even crazier we
now know harold's office was also the
room that stephen went up to in episode
two and it features the exact same
columns in recess that that place does
beyond that there's also the any ad who
work much in the same way that a council
at a hospital does too whenever a
patient accuses a doctor of abuse and
neglect they're called before a group of
doctors much like what we saw in episode
three now nine times out of ten the
doctor is believed over the patient who
tends to bring up their mental illness
to downplay what's going on i'm gonna
talk about my theories for the finale
next week but i just wanted to drop this
in first to highlight it and i
appreciate you sitting through the
section if you've seen us mention it
about 50 times in other videos that
we've done this week much appreciated
you're the best see you chump
so going off this conversation you can
kind of see that mark might be imagining
the entire thing especially with the
jumping back and forth or i could just
be sat in my own hospital right now
refusing to let go of a fan theory my
beautiful beautiful fan theory
anyway the injection sets him off again
and we meet the goddess who says they're
dead as shakira said hippos don't lie
dearly that's a bad one and she
introduces herself she also informs them
that they're in duet the underworld in
egyptian mythology is also the mention
of the ancestral plane from black
panther which she calls gorgeous she
very much repeats notions of what harrow
said and informs them that it's too
difficult for the human mind to perceive
so things are put in place to resemble a
familiar environment
going down the rabbit hole that this is
all real there have been several things
in the series that of course popped him
in the hospital and i totally forgot to
mention that donna said this in episode
one listen if you don't stop nattering
at me i swear i'll shove you in a
sarcophagus
stephen of course was also found in a
sarcophagus so hey it's all connected
hey conchae and i thought my jokes were
bad
ontario is the goddess of fertility and
also childbirth in mythology she married
the god of lurk and has seen over many
children and women interestingly she was
also charged with guiding souls of
people that died which kinda ties into
what's going on here there's lots of
things that call back to ancient
egyptian mythology and typically people
used to believe that when one died that
their heart would be weighed in the
afterlife if they were bad then they'd
get eaten by the crocodile god amit and
this also ties in why harrow has the
scales to do as well the egyptians
believe that death was not the end and
then it was simply a transition into
another part of an eternal journey the
field of reads was very much the
idealized version of someone's life that
was a paradise they gained access to
after passing through the hall of truth
this episode is all about balancing the
scales but unfortunately by the end that
means that steven has to die granted
grunt dead eh and i i must admit i had
some tears in my eyes as this moment
played out i've really grown fond of the
guy over the last five weeks and i hope
this isn't the end now it does sort of
follow similar beats to the end of loki
episode 5 when the titular character was
also seemingly killed though we don't
get a post-credit scene i do think
steven will be back as there's not
really a way for a personality to die in
someone's mind typically in d.i.d
although end up either merging or going
dormant which i can kinda see happening
here this however also leaves the door
open for jack lockley who gets hinted at
in the entry again we've had several
clues to him throughout the season and
with him being more of a killer than
mark and stephen the former may turn to
him in order to help now jake was never
really an assassin in the comics but
stephen was never really a bumbling
cockney either so much in the same way
that they've changed steven up they
could change jacob too and make him a
hitman of something that's going to be a
very valuable asset mark is probably
going to get freed by kunchu who we get
lip service 2 being possibly freed by
leila in the comics he's brought mark
back to life at several points but we'll
talk about that later in the video i
forgot to point out last week but notice
how mark is wearing light colors whereas
steven is wearing dark the pair are some
opposites to each other which is
reflected in this bit of costume design
the show has done a really good job of
tying in the clothes with the characters
and their personalities and this series
has been laced with mark stephen wearing
white hoodies at several points steven
also wore this top in episode 1 and
typically darkness of course represents
death whereas white represents light
potentially foreshadowing the outcome of
this entry or potentially it's a reach
anyway after trying to rationalize the
situation mark makes it even worse by
opening the doorway to reveal where they
really are this is a giant boat riding
through the dunes surrounded by the dead
the ancient egyptians did believe that
when they died they'd be ferried across
the river styx by sharon so this is sort
of riffing on that now this boat of
course appeared in steven's fish tank
all the way back in the first episode it
adds a really trippy aesthetic to the
whole thing and it also pulls from the
comics moonite has never actually ridden
one of these to the best of my knowledge
however it did show up in the heroic age
prince of power with loki and thor the
pair ended up climbing aboard it to get
a sarcophagus which might have inspired
the show now this whole episode is based
massively on the jeff lemire run which
seemingly takes place in an asylum
before it's revealed to be the other
void it's a buck we've milked more than
squid game videos but if this is your
first time watching one of our
breakdowns then i think we kind of have
to go over it a huge shout out to our
editor matt who got all of the bingo
numbers from last week and found a
pretty cool easter egg with them crawley
called out all the numbers in the
background of the scene and if you added
these up it took you to 174. the marvel
legacy numbering started at issue 188
and if we took a step back to what would
be issue 174 we ended up with lumiere
issue 1 aka the asylum story and the
first part of the book deals with mark
in mercy hospital for the mentally ill
which he's apparently been in since he
was 12. overseen by dr remich he says
he's been there most of his life and
that the entire moonlight character is
all a fantasy this is backed up by the
characters that join him there such as
crawley and also marlene now marlene was
the loving dress for mark in the comics
and we had it confirmed earlier in the
week by muhammad diab that she was
originally in the script for the show
however he pushed for her to be changed
to an egyptian character and after some
alterations to the backstory leila was
born now mark dreamed he was dying and
he had a vision of kunchu who told him
this was all an illusion inside a vessel
called the other void that existed
outside of time and space it was
revealed emmet was actually omit and her
orderlies bobby and billy were in fact
jackals mark ended up dressing himself
in bed sheets and pillowcases and along
with the other people from his life he
escaped into the basement of the
hospital from here he ran into mummies
and after he made it past this his
personalities all split and they all
kind of went off into their own
adventures steven was a movie producer
who was working on the set for a
production of moon knight which featured
both him and also midnight man jake
lockley was a cabbie who was suspected
of murder there was also a space pilot
called moon knight and we jumped from
scenario to scenario throughout the book
seeing things from their perspective as
we unraveled the mystery although omit
took the blame for it in the end it was
revealed it was actually konju who
created the entire scenario because he
wanted to break mark's mind so that he
could take over his body he jumped into
his past and learned more about his
childhood namely how he created his
imaginary friend stephen who helped him
through things when they got tough now
this is something that sort of happens
in the episode but on top of it the
comics revealed that konchu had actually
been there his entire life and that he
wasn't just someone who popped up when
mark made the deal with him in the issue
in which he spent a lot of time with
mark's father konchu actually said that
he was his real dad and we're gonna have
to get on the maury show for that should
have used a con dom hey con shoot on me
oh wait wait this kid's watching
ignore what i said there now he'd
constructed a clean that everything
around him to grab his body and over the
years he'd slowly chipped away at his
mind in order to take over him the book
ended with all the personalities coming
together and joined as one they finally
killed konchu now i don't think this
will happen in the show as kanji seems
more like he's trying to stop ahmet but
it is an important twist in the comics
to bear in mind now along with mark's
childhood the book also featured
sections about his transformation into
moon knight which we'll get into in just
a bit a taroup pulls their heart out
which this episode did to me too and
they appear almost like marble on the
scales they have a chaotic rocking back
and forth motion much like what happened
with harrow's tattoo in episode 1. the
scales themselves didn't feature in the
jeff lemire run but there was a similar
choice made to what he does at the end
mark had to leave behind crawley who was
taken by anubis into the other void and
in order to get him back he had to
rescue the guard's wife who had been
locked down there normally a myth
harouet didn't really have anything to
do with this but they've kind of
combined her with being a guide and also
a judge this could also lead into the
gods that we saw trapped at the start of
episode 4 and potentially she's having
to do both jobs because they're
imprisoned a version of this that's more
in line with how it appeared in
mythology also showed up in the comics
namely hellstrom son of satan this
appeared more like what we typically see
in the legends with anubis being the one
who judged and there was amet ready to
eat your heart out if your soul was
heavier than a feather anubis does
however appear on the scale itself but
the character is completely missing from
the entry she says that they have to
show each other the truth before they
reach the field of reads episode 1 also
had mention of this when the girl talked
about him getting rejected from the
field of reads potentially setting this
up
and did it suck for you getting rejected
from the field of rates what if that
makes sense because i'm not dead am i
stevie
steven questioned whether he was dead
and yeah a really nice bit of
foreshadowing that shows they're they're
all still in the asylum i'm telling you
they're all still in the asylum now they
want to break out and save layla but
they must confront their past first and
the trauma that got them there you get
flashes of the bathroom fight the night
sky being turned back and also another
qr code if you've been keeping up with
the series then you'll know that you get
a free comic if you scan these and
grabbing this one takes you to moonlight
issue 1 from 1980. beside this door we
see a version of the character standing
drinking with a taxi in the background i
did think this might be jake but it's
revealed to be mark who can't bear the
weight on his soul later it's revealed
that this is his mother's shiver which
is the period of mourning that comes
after a jewish funeral i think it's sort
of the equivalent to awake but gonna be
honest i'm not fully versed up on this
stuff and i don't want to seem
disrespectful so if it's got a different
name please leave the correction in the
comments below and i apologize here now
they end up entering a cafe filled with
dead bodies and these are revealed to be
mark's victims are there were slight
hints to these bodies being in this
hospital if it is a hospital all the way
back in episode 2 in harrow's office
conscious took out these people for
being predators murderers and people who
didn't hit the thumbs up button and
clearly it weighs on mark's soul however
after confronting them the scales start
to balance out a bit there's a lovely
little detail here as well with one of
the corpses that has a cat that says
odin who is also dead yay now the piece
is broken when a mysterious child shows
up who leads stephen into mark's past at
this point we catch his mother running
the barbecue and also meet his little
brother roro this is clearly randall
specter who you'll be well aware of if
you're familiar with the comics like his
brother he joined the cia and became a
cold-blooded assassin whereas mark
became moonlight randall ended up
becoming the villain hatchet man before
he turned into shadow knight he's a
terrifying character and there is
potential that he shows up down the line
as a villain in the future even with the
death scene i think it would be a big
twist to have him come back and with it
being the thing that started to fracture
mark's mind it's a very cool twist now
we also have him drawing a goldfish with
one fin which stephen of course kept as
a pet mark also says the phrase later
skaters to say goodbye which stephen of
course said in episode one latest gators
a wild crocodile
anyway sorry mr mum i'll try again
tomorrow late as gators
now we did theorize that stephen's
mother was dead and we get it confirmed
in this entry though leila brought her
up in episode two it's clear mark didn't
tell her what really happened in order
to seem somewhat normal the postcards
were also likely sent from him and we
did actually see them up at stephen's
work at one point in the first episode
it's something we theorized all the way
back then and i oh we've had some misses
nice to get one right shabbat now steven
being nice to her on the phone could
very much be mark trying to repair the
guilt that he felt over causing his
brother's death which he blames him for
together they play as dr grant and rossa
the characters we met in last week's
tomb buster stephen also steps on the
skeleton of a hummingbird which has a
similar head to consu this of course is
what one of the patients drew last week
and as i've been saying
it's all connected
at this point we see the waterfall and
his brother sadly dies after the cave
they're in floods elsewhere mark visits
the memory of his brother's shiva which
leans heavily into his jewish heritage
in the comics it was his father's but i
do appreciate the change up which kind
of leads into his relationship with his
mother being destroyed really nice
getting in this episode as they had kind
of shied away from it throughout most of
the series though we did see a star of
david necklace on the character at the
end of episode 2. we can see this chain
around steven's neck in this entry as
well and it's such an important aspect
of the character that i'm glad they
acknowledged it it's clear that mark's
mother wendy completely shuts down
emotionally after the death of his
brother and she avoided most of his
birthdays she sank into a deep
depression started drinking heavily and
all kind of leads into why mark formed
his did this is something that is
created from childhood trauma and it's
really heartbreaking watching all these
scenes mark ends up leaving and we cut
to the desert to see one of the darkest
parts of his life now in the comics mark
was part of the marines but after he was
kicked out he ended up becoming a
mercenary mark partnered up with another
mayor called ralph bushman who wore
death's head tattooed over his face to
terrify those he was going into battle
with bushmen was a complete psychopath
and the two went together to a dig site
that had unearthed the temple for the
moon god konshu realizing he could get
rich if he stole all the jewels he ended
up killing all the archaeologists there
and just left behind the door of the
head one who was marlene and mark tried
to stop this but bushman ended up
beating himself badly that he was left
in hippocritical condition because
tarauet wasn't there a hypocritical
joke
anyway marlene and the locals in the
area that worshiped the god took mark
before the shrine and after he made a
deal with consu to become his avatar on
earth he ended up transforming into
moonlight now whereas here we see mark
actually transform into the character
like he has in the show in the comics he
just grabbed the cloak off the statue
and put it around him moonlight very
much to start off as a pretty
straightforward character that was
basically just batman but don't tell
people i said that but over the years
they've kind of added in more of the
supernatural stuff to flesh him out a
lot and distance him from that konchi
himself has also gone through several
redesigns as well and initially he just
started off as a normal statue like what
we see here which kind of evolved into
the bird head egyptian gods typically
tend to have animal traits to them so i
can kinda see why they decided to change
things up moonlight went and got revenge
on bushmen and the pair have had many
battles over the years mark even cut his
face off at one point which brought a
whole new meaning to the skull tattoo
that he of course has now bushman gets
mentioned in this entry so this could
possibly set up him showing off bully at
some point in an upcoming show of film
every time i bring up oscar isaac
returning someone in the comments points
out that he said this is a one and done
but meh still lots of stories to tell
and i'd daddy turn it down if mickey
showed up to the house with one million
dollars cash cool hard cash one million
now amongst this area we catch layla's
father who's wearing a scarlet scarf
much like what harrow said he had on in
episode 4. we can also see the scarab
markings on it and this clearly weighs
heavily on mark's soul now it is
possible that they're setting layla up
to become the scarlet scarab throughout
the series she's been referred to as one
at several points due to the nickname
that her father gave her as a child
i wonder what your father would think of
his little scarab now
my little scare
isn't that what your father used to call
you
be honest though laylah's full name is
laila abdullah al fawley and the scarlet
scarab in the comics is called abdel fal
in hospital she also has a thimble on
her finger which when we zoom in has a
little scarlet scarab on it in the
comics he fought against captain america
and co and it is possible that layla
might even end up taking the mantle come
the end of the show now together they
walk towards the temple of konchu which
is ripped right out of the comics this
is even down to the way it's lit but
they change up the moon from a full one
to a crescent one so it's more in line
with moonlight symbol originally though
mark was carried before the shrine in
the jeff lemire run they change it up so
that he crawled towards it which this
episode recaptures perfectly before he
ends his life konju calls out to him and
the pair make a deal mark very much
sells his soul and this is somewhat a
deal with the devil the bird from before
could tease that he's been with him
since a kid and who knows his control of
the elements could have meant that he
killed his brother might be a big reveal
next week and that's the shortest ever
theory time era time time
and they travel back to the boat and we
see purple glows raining down this pulls
from the dark dimension and it signals
that harrow is freeing omit who is
condemning souls on mass terror starts
to steer towards the gate of osiris and
the pair tried desperately to balance
out the scales markets heated and
refuses to go back which is when we cut
back to harold's office in a complete
mind again now he says that they can't
involuntarily sedate patients but hey i
seen it with his net planned his
mustache he pondered in lyondes whether
more created stephen to hide from all
the horrors he committed or if stephen
created mark to punish the world for
their mother's actions after looking at
his reflection and a glass of water we
cut to the two toon buster figures this
is done without going through the
doorways and i'll keep banging on about
this theory yeah but it might he might
just be imagining the whole thing but
i'll move on now they lean heavily into
the comics at this point as well and
mark's room is extremely similar to how
it is in the source material you can
also catch the framed image of the
goldfish and we learn that his mother is
very much perceived as having another
personality by mock he says she's not
his mother and she brutally beats and
abuses him which is absolutely
heartbreaking he shifts into stephen's
body in front of the mirror in order to
hide himself from his mother and we see
not only the scales but also a poster
for toon buster in the comics this was
an indiana jones one but they clearly
changed it up to show why he adopted the
stephen graham persona at this point
stephen shifts to the office and what a
in mind
now i don't think anyone can 100 confirm
what's real and what's not which i
really love harrow states that after his
mother passed that they checked into the
hospital and he called dylan which is
the name of the girl that stephen
organized a date with in episode 1. she
gets his mother's number but before they
even speak he accepts her death and we
cut to her shiver we learned that this
is when their lives started bleeding
together and stephen tells him it wasn't
his fault which kind of helps the
character's soul they reach the gates
but they're closed and with the scales
being unbalanced they're unable to open
up thus the dead start to climb aboard
and attack them which is when steven
throws himself and he's sent overboard
stephen dies in the dunes which balances
the scales and mark is taken to the
field of reeds over the top of this we
hear the song masala del sol which
translates to somewhere over the sun
year mark remains which closes out the
episode now as for next week i think
that things are going to go a bit by the
numbers because they it's a disney plus
show and outside of loki they've all
kind of wrapped up things in a pretty
standard way from the teasers we have
shots of munite and harrow jumping
towards one another whilst the moon is
full which sort of brings things full
circle from how it was in the jackal
chase now i think that mark will meet
another avatar here and after he escapes
he'll make it back to the surface like i
said earlier i do think that steven will
be back in some form or another and they
might even get jake involved too as he's
been teased at so heavily they kind of
need the trifecta to pull it off and
layla is going to be instrumental in
getting konshu and then resurrecting
mark he's done this so many times in the
comics before and due to the suits
regenerative qualities it could be what
brings him back from the brink after the
god is freed huge head out to add mcu
geeky on twitter for going back and
forth with me over these theories and in
the end i can see him defeating harrow
and racing all the personas in his life
and getting the girl now i do think that
they might do something to kind of tease
that this is all still in his head and
potentially they might end on either the
b22 bingo ball or something like the
moonlight figure i really think they'll
go ambiguous with it so we can argue
forever until we find something to do
with our meaningless lives but as we
mentioned earlier there are a lot of
clues that this whole thing's in mark's
head i kind of hope they end like that
just to keep us talking about the show
but there's also the possibility that
they might tease the midnight suns again
isaac hasn't confirmed that he's coming
back but when you have dane whitman and
blade in one part of london at a museum
it makes sense to get the other
characters in the city involved with
them in case you don't know they're
basically a team that fights
supernatural beings in the marvel
universe and we could also get
characters like ghost rider involved
with them too lots of things to look
forward to and the series just feels
like it's building up really well and
kind of capitalizing on a lot of comics
and interesting aspects of moonlight's
history to tell us a rich story i will
of course be back next week and sorry
for being a bit late on the breakdown
today really want to apologize if you
set up refreshing youtube all day for
when i've dropped the video which thanks
a lot but uh yeah never never rely on
kevin spoilers he's not a good guy give
me a video you'll get video when you fix
this damn door
now as some of you know that's because
marvel only gave out the first four
episodes in advance so kind of rolling
with it today instead of just watching
the episode on a friday and putting
stuff together throughout the weekend in
the weekdays anyway i hope you enjoyed
what was put out thumbs up is much
appreciated and i hope to see you back
next week we are in a competition right
now we're giving away three copies of
spider-man noway home on the 15th of may
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode if you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers however you want to watch a
breakdown of all the evidence in the
series to show that it's a mark's head
then that'll be linked on screen right
now really good video put a lot of time
into it and yeah
you're not doing anything else are you
go check it out so all the other
youtubers they might not have uploaded
their breakdown yet so uh yeah you stuck
with me for now and i appreciate that
that you are stuck with me and that you
chose me i love you and i'll see you
next week take care peace